[Music]
let's go to david in raleigh north
carolina one of the most beautiful
cities in the country what's up david
hey john thank you so much to you and uh
mostly kelly i guess for having me on
the show come on
i'm sorry hey listen she called last
night and was like uh i've got like
seven calls and i said we're getting
david on this show
just kidding that didn't happen at all
fake news
and that fake news is fake news how do
you like them apples
i'm just kidding david yes you can think
kelly she's the best and great and
wonderful and brilliant and
blah blah so anyway hey brother david
what is up man
well i just want to say um i've got so
much respect for you and what you do and
how you approach mental health so just
thank you for what you do i'm grateful
for you too john
oh i see what you did there thanks man
so hey i'm grateful for you too so
what's up man
yeah so
um i got a call from my mom two weeks
ago
saying that my brother who was deployed
in afghanistan was one of the 13 service
members killed in the kabul bombing come
on man i'm so sorry
wow yeah it's it's um
it's complex because my
my mom just remarried two years ago okay
and i've only met only met the guy once
okay so i don't really have
any kind of relationship with this guy
so i'm just kind of
trying to navigate i have a good you
know good relationship with my mom and
my stepdad and i'm just trying to figure
out how i can
be there for my mom because this is we
just we just grieved my dad passing five
years ago so
it's it's a lot of grieving and you know
i'm tired of
tired of her having to deal with crap
like this yeah man it's hard
everything about this is hard man um man
she's lucky to have you in her life for
thinking about her and for loving her
and um
dang man that sucks i'm heartbroken for
your family
so five years ago your old man passes
away was it sudden was it quick was it
slow
he yeah he had a heart disease it was a
very
very slow decline but it was
it was a quick quick death so you know
he was slowly you know his legs were
starting to swell and he was kind of
slowing down not able to exercise as
much but it wasn't like okay he's gonna
pass you know we know he's gonna pass it
was it was very sudden
gotcha
so
then she gets remarried a few years
later is that right
yeah okay and then she
i mean these servicemen that passed away
were so stinking young so she's probably
spent a year or two with them
yeah so they um
my stepdad they had a good relationship
with him
um he's been
stationed
out here near i don't i don't actually
know it's somewhere out here in north
carolina
but uh so they got to see them quite a
lot okay
so
how did your mom reach out to you
well
she had she's been texting me saying hey
because he had just gotten deployed
my step brother just got deployed like
several days before it happened so
it was
hey you know pray for ryan he's going to
afghanistan yeah and then
on
thursday it was hey
we haven't heard from him
um you know be praying that he's safe
and then i wake up to a call from her
and she's not she's not one to have a
quick conversation but it was it was
very quick it was
he was he was just killed uh pray for
pray for your stepdad yeah
man
man so have you been able to see your
mom in person
no
she's there over in tennessee so it's a
bit of a drive okay
so
when anyone says like hey how do i help
somebody grieve
especially when someone's a family
member especially someone's involved in
this loss in any way
and um
the first thing i always tell folks is
make sure you're grieving
make sure you're dealing with your
frustration and your anger and your loss
and like you said you didn't know this
guy very well but there's some
peripheral connection there right and
you just yeah as a fellow united states
citizen like the rest of us are just
horrified at this thing
um and so
you you making sure you're okay and not
okay you're not just gonna flip a switch
but making sure that you have a process
you've got people in your life you're
taking care of your
basic health needs and things like that
and you've got folks that you can talk
to that's super critical to make sure
you can be whole in the presence of
somebody who's hurting right
um
i think it's worth how old are you man
i'm 23. 23.
are you working
are you in school what are you doing
right now
yeah i'm i'm i'm married and i've got a
i'm self-employed okay
if at all possible i think being in
proximity with your mom even if it's
24-48 hours is really valuable right now
um being able to let her touch you and
hug you and kiss your face
and hold her hand
um feels like a what would i actually i
mean what am i gonna do i'm just gonna
sit there and i would tell you yes
absolutely you'll just sit there
and maybe you
take her by the hand and you'll go get
some breakfast or some go to dinner or
something together um you are able to
hug your father-in-law
your step-dad if you will not
father-in-law your stepdad you're able
to hug him and again he didn't know you
that well but he's connected in in
different ways
and your role will take on a different
you know meaning to him but
being able to just be seen and be
touched and you hold your mom will
be a healing
it will be magical healing if you will
and so if you can knock off 48 hours i
know it's a long drive it's an
exhausting drive but if you can make
that drive or catch a flight and
um go hug your mom
i would really recommend that i've done
turn around trips like that for drive 12
hours or nine hours for 10 hours of
sitting by somebody to then turn around
and drive another 9 or 10 or 11 hours
back
those moments are magical and they are a
gift and they are few and far between
um as it as trying to love somebody and
help them grieve long distance
the magic here is not i keep saying
magic because it's a mystical process in
many ways
the magic is to not try to fix your mom
you can't you can't take away her hurt
you can't take her away her disbelief
you can't take away
this is a big one right this one's got a
lot of baggage to it because there's so
many different voices weighing in and
every time she turns on the news there
it is and every time she doesn't turn on
the news there it is and facebook groups
and texting and
the military processionals all that
stuff
is just this reminder and this constant
reminder and it's part of the healing
process
and so not trying to get caught up in a
trap of hey mom here's what you need to
do
but more of hey mom how are you
how's today
how was yesterday
and not always doing it through text but
setting up time when i'm going to call
mom i want to hear her voice and she
needs to hear your voice
does that make sense
yeah
um what has the last few weeks been like
for y'all are y'all are you talking to
her is she in a is she
weeping i mean
how is she doing
yeah so um i called her
um you know i gave them a day or two
for the you know because i didn't want
to talk to them when they're just in
complete shock so i called her and like
two or three days after
uh was obviously still in shock but
called her just to say
hey
you know how are you what's what's it
been like
and it was
you know i could tell that they had been
kind of crying a lot and they were they
said you know lots of ups and downs
but
most mostly
just crap about
news stations trying to get a hold of
them trying to interview them
been approached by some major
film industries about already filming a
documentary and trying to interview them
so it's a lot of
dealing with a lot of crap like that
so
here's something else um my house and a
lot of this credit to my wife she's
she's amazing but
my house has become a place that people
will escape to
they'll come from all over the country
and come spend a couple of days or a
week or two and get away
and it may be that you reaching out to
your mom and saying i want to invite you
to raleigh
you all get off the grid
turn your phones off and just come see
us you don't need to be able to heal
where people don't know where you live
they're not going to sit outside your
house i'm going to follow you to the
grocery store
and media and film i mean they can be
relentless
and maybe offering a safe place for her
to come visit you and you have do you
have a little
one no we don't okay you have a dog
no we've got just a spare bedroom all
right get a dog and tell your mom
grant i don't know be one of those
people that says things like grand dog
or whatever those people who
have animals and they try to
anthropomorphize them into humans um do
that do something tell you got a
squirrel in the backyard that needs her
grand squirrel or something but invite
her to come stay with you she probably
won't but
um really open that up and yeah i really
think you need to go see her face to
face
um so this happened today and i'll keep
this as broad as possible because i i
want to keep my friend's personal life
um personal but
we got a call this morning that friends
um people that like some of my closest
friends on the whole planet um they had
called 9-1-1 one of them um was real
sick and ended up uh
going to the hospital this morning so
i'm waiting here after this show i'll
get some updates on the way things are
going
when i heard that
i immediately picked up the phone and
called
and so this idea of i don't wanna i know
they're grieving and i don't wanna get
in the middle of that
if you love them and you're connected
get in the middle
let people know that you're thinking
about them can i do anything how are you
because a lot of people like you
mentioned will call because they want
something
they want to know information they want
to know
um
how
how the grieving people are gonna make
me feel better because i'm scared and
i'm alone and i'm angry too
and there's something about just cutting
through that stuff and saying i'm your
son how are you right so i would
encourage you to not wait
they'll tell you they won't answer the
phone the guy i called this morning
whose wife is in the hospital he didn't
answer but he knows that i love him and
i left him a message and said don't call
me back just want you know i'm thinking
about you praying about you i'm thinking
um uh if you need anything holler at me
and just want to check in on you
those kind of things they people won't
always remember what you said they'll
remember that they heard your voice
they'll remember that they saw your face
and so you lean in against your own
discomfort and you call your mom every
day make sure she's doing okay invite
her to see her see you you show up
um but there's gonna be a process about
touch and care and connection in these
moments
don't try to fix your mom she's gonna
have a hard grieving season your stepdad
especially is gonna have a hard grieving
season
just think of how can i be with
not how can i fix does that make sense
yeah and then over time as your mom
begins to make meaning of this deal as
she begins to say what am i going to do
am i going to create a group for
um recently deployed young men and women
and i'm gonna create a group for their
moms or
i'm gonna create a group for grieving
parents or as she begins to make meaning
of this and say the rest of my life is
gonna be about x y and z because of this
um then you can support her and love her
and go to the 10ks and go to the rallies
or
be you know a guest writer on her blog
whatever it's gonna look like for her
um but she's gonna always know you were
there and you're walking alongside her
and again i want to remind you
you're peripheral peripherally is that a
right word you were connected to this
you know six degrees of kevin bacon but
you're still connected to it
you're still gonna have people who reach
out to you you're still going to have
your own
when you're watching the news or you're
frustrated or you see politicians trying
to spin this this way or that way
make sure you're dealing with your own
stuff that you're keeping a journal
you're writing stuff down you're
disconnecting yourself from some of
these feelings and your anger and your
rage and your frustration or your
sadness make sure you're dealing with
you man
because you lost your old man too a few
years ago i know your your mom lost her
husband but you lost your dad
and now you're watching your mom hurt
again and that's hard too it's all about
grief
and you're gonna listen to all the
different knuckleheaded friends you have
making their cases and saying this and
that's make sure you and your wife are
dealing with your grief too
and over time you're gonna find meaning
also
and i'll say this your mom's lucky to
have you man
to all the sons and daughters out there
let's love our parents when they're
grieving when they're heartbroken when
they're hurting
let's reach out let's let's i know it's
awkward because they usually come to us
for our whole lives they've been taking
care of us and there's these moments
that it turns when it's our job to reach
out to them and say how are you doing
and
just be honest this is a season of loss
so much loss
whether it's
go over deaths whether it's military pet
i mean there's so much loss loss lots
hurricane stuff
we gotta cut through the
man
it feels weird or it's hard i don't know
what to say forget that call somebody
and say hey i love you i don't know what
to say right now but i love you
send the email send the text write the
letters make the calls
we need each other during the season of
grief we don't need your anger and don't
need your
we need you just to reach out and care
for each other
david you're awesome brother thank you
so much um
and we honor your stepbrother we honor
him and the other 12
with all of our hearts and our minds and
we honor them by the way
by loving each other by getting up and
saying i'm going to make the most of
today i'm going to make the most of
tomorrow
i'm going to be kind i'm going to be
direct i'm going to be honest i'm going
to love each other that's how we're
going to honor
we take care of our commitments we're
going to do what we say
thank you so much for you dave and your
family